-Alright. Millie, we're going to
play a game.
This is the
whisper challenge, okay?
But it's going to work
a little different
because we're
talking through Zoom.
So, the singing
whisper challenge,
since you're a great singer and
since we're doing this on Zoom,
what we're going to do is --
one of us will mute
the computer's speakers,
and the other person
will start singing a random song
that we've assigned you,
and I don't know what it is.
And you don't know what I have.
And we'll have to guess what
they're singing
just by reading their lips.
Does that make sense?
-Okay. Alright, got it.
-I'm going to mute.
Should I mute now?
-Yeah.
-Here comes the mute.
That's it. I can't hear you.
I can't hear you.
-Can you not hear me?
[ Laughs ]
Sorry. Okay. Okay. Alright.
Okay. Oh, okay. Ready?
Here we go.
♪ Don't show up ♪
♪ Don't come out ♪
♪ Don't start caring
about me now ♪
-Oh.
♪ Walk away ♪
♪ Say good night ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
It's Dua Lipa.
It's "Don't Stop Now" or
"Don't Start Now."
-"Don't Start." Yeah.
-Was I right?
-"Don't Start Now" by Dua Lipa.
-"Don't Start Now," Dua Lipa!
Yeah, that was great!
♪ Walk away ♪
Okay.
-And walking out.
I was like, "Wait."
-♪ Walk away ♪
-I was like, "Don't walk,"
"don't stop."
Alright, that was great.
Okay.
Alright. Alright. Perfect.
I love that.
It was working.
I didn't hear anything.
Alright, you ready for mine?
-Yes, ready.
-You have to press "mute"
so you can't hear me.
-Okay, got it.
-Now can you hear me?
-No.
-Alright, here's my jam.
♪ Now the day bleeds
into nightfall ♪
♪ And you're not here
to get me through it all ♪
♪ I let my guard down ♪
♪ And you pulled the rug ♪
-This is insane.
Post Malone?
-No.
-You look insane.
-That's how I sing.
-You look like you're singing
like Post Malone would sing.
I'm just --
-♪ Now the day bleeds
into nightfall ♪
♪ And you're not here
to get me through it all ♪
-Can you please
you stop doing this
and do, like, a different mouth?
-♪ I was just getting kind of
used to being
someone you loved ♪
-You love? Love.
-Yep.
-Love.
"Lose You to Love Me."
-Nope.
-This is so tough!
Okay, go ahead. Keep going.
-Someone. Someone.
-Somewhere over.
-Someone.
-Somewhere.
-Someone, you.
-Somewhere. You.
Love.
-Someone you love.
-"Someone You Love."
"Someone You Love" by
Lewis Capaldi.
-Yes! That's it.
Yes! That was it.
-Well done.
I mean,
it was actually very tough.
And, also, you don't move
your mouth a lot,
so you just look like
this to me.
-Oh, my gosh.
-You looked crazy.
-I'm so sorry.
That's how I sing.
It's so funny.
Alright,
we'll do one more round.
This is you singing.
I'm going to mute.
-♪ Despacito ♪
-Nice pants, dude.
♪ This is how we
do it down in Puerto Rico ♪
♪ I just want to hear you
screamin'...♪
[ Laughs ]
-Do I look crazy?
-Okay, I'm going to dance.
-Yes, go.
-Okay, ready?
Here we go. Do it again.
♪ Despacito ♪
♪ This is how we
do it down in Puerto Rico ♪
-What is going on?
You're rockin' out. It's so fun.
I have no idea
what you're doing.
It's...
-Okay, ready? Read my lips.
-Alright, let's go.
-Des-pa-cito.
♪ Despacito ♪
-Let's go one word by one word.
-Des.
-Let's.
-Des. De-De-De.
-Deck.
-Des-s.
-Death?
-[ Laughs ]
-Dest.
-Des.
-Des?
-Pa. Pa.
-By.
-Cito.
[ Both laugh ]
-Cisco.
Wait. Despa-- "Despacito"!
-Yes!
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
Oh, my God. The best.
Millie, I love you so much.
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
-Thank you so much.
-You are the greatest.
Guys, donate to unicef.org.
You are the coolest.
I love you, love you, love you.
-Thank you. Bye.
-Bye, pal. Thank you.